Come on, y'all.
Moz, Cocoa, and the kids moving back home;
it's Black Family Magic.
Smile, there you go.
We're one big happy family,
under one happy roof.
I hope you been studying.
No!
You need to teach me how you do that.
It's a gift, baby.
Black Family Magic is being together.
Sticking together.
And praying together.
Jesus, help me!
It's doing everything
with a little bit of attitude.
Hey, Jade!
Do I know you?
Black Family Magic is confusing.
Oh, I don't even want to know.
It's M'Dears sweet potato pie.
Can I get some of... Dad?
Black Family Magic
is snapping peas on the porch.
Snap the ends off
while we engage in conversation.
That's what the old folks call "Snapchat."
It's time for the McKellan slide!